[Music]
it's uh he was in he's all that
I love that still softish he's a
composer of still softish hey man that's
a sick IMDb credit I wonder if we're
credited as composers I don't think we
are is our music on IMDb it should be so
we do we do have our music videos on
IMDb I guess and we're composers of them
yeah composer man we did a lot
it's kind of a lot man look at that [ __ ]
yeah that's pretty impressive yeah damn
there really are videos for each one of
those I know that's what I'm saying
separate music video for each one of
those
I'm not proud of No Flex dude that's a
good one you like that video yes oh I
felt like I failed this so hard no no
it's a great video also I was just
looking this morning for some reason
that pseudo club scene we did in your
garage I was I I think about that moment
so fondly to be honest one of those
moments where it's like we don't have
any resources yeah okay we need to put
out something like tomorrow yeah so what
the [ __ ] are we gonna do and we're like
you're like we can use your garage I
guess
did we ever ever talk about that no I
don't think we've ever gone into it do
you want to pull up the video and play
that part or just let it play silently
yeah don't let a single note all right
so hold on hold on before you say that
this song has 21 million streams on
Spotify that's absurd it's insane so
this was just like a run and Gun
music video
and we got those scooters because some
company followed me I think and I yeah
reached out to them and was like hey
this is they were like so this this that
scene right there that's in my garage
that's just one ring light
I pulled my car out of the garage yep
and we brought a smoke machine in there
yeah a fog machine yeah I was like we'd
throw a bunch of the [ __ ] Haze in
here we might be able to make it look
like something and the scooter company I
was like hit them up I was like can you
we're filming a music video tomorrow can
you bring
holy yeah I forgot about that yeah
and that's it whose house is that at it
was just the
we like I think I found the cheapest
location on peer space I was like we got
like a hundred bucks
this is like I'm like yeah what can we
get
it was such a weird concept it's not a
bad video at all
[Music]
yeah it's all right
I mean I'm mostly proud of the garage
all right
it was it was definitely doing a lot of
the little you know tough to beat stay
safe I feel like stay safe
is the best no budget video yeah because
I was looking I was like looking at how
many streams my song has and then I was
like how many streams is Walkman still
getting so I switched the artist thing
in the Spotify app and I was just on the
on the drive here literally looking at
Stats Walkman still gets 18 000 streams
every day that's insane it's at 87
million streams it has to be almost Gold
by now I'll tell you 10 of those streams
every Friday night come from random bars
in the Midwest and the Northeast I can I
can promise you that where else would
they come 18 000 people are still
listening to that song and I put it on
in the car because I was like I wonder
if this holds up it doesn't yeah it's
bad yeah your verse is good ah thanks
man but no everything else is just like
holy [ __ ] there are still people in the
gym maybe that put this on are like
it's definitely in Des Moines yeah their
music it's so funny when I go to things
like four years behind dude it's so
funny shout out to Des Moines Funny Bone
staff there amazing everyone great had
an amazing time but their playlist is
bad it wasn't bad it just [ __ ] me up
they had Dirt Off Your Shoulder
that's a great song maybe it was like a
throwback playlist yeah I was like
working out this new bit where I like
talk about Yeet I said Yeet I said the
joke and one night none of those people
ever heard yeat in their life really
yeah you mentioned him and it was just
like crickets yeah there were like these
two like Euphoria girls in the front
yeah they look like Euphoria extras they
were like oh my God he is [ __ ] not it
yeah and everyone else this is this oh
it was you know they look like you know
I got money
they look rich minion they look like the
deer that we fantasized about hitting
yeah yeah yeah
it's so funny too there's always one
show where you gotta open up the tickets
to like let a bunch of solos in and then
you get a bunches
yeah I mean who goes solo to a comedy
show well you I it's always I'm joking I
always I'm totally joking no no it's
great it's great you're lame though no
there's a guy who came by himself and I
told him I was like I I love the
confidence dude you look like you murder
women but I love that you're here just
you know don't touch anyone on your way
out I always figure it out too late
there's always one show where everyone's
like has like this I don't know if tepid
is the right word but it's just sort of
like and then I then at 50 minutes I'll
be like are you guys sitting with
strangers look like yeah oh God yeah
yeah I started trying to laugh hot yes
yes they're like
okay
there was a case any other neighbors or
it was this guy
there's this guy sitting with a lady and
I go uh I'm like is this your girl and
he goes nah we just uh I wish I mean
sorry he's like nah we just um we don't
know each other get his arm around yeah
no he had his arm like posted up on her
seat uh there was a like a small like
wall behind them so he was like kind of
posted up like this okay and I started
laughing because before I even said that
I just looked at him and he looked at me
and he went
up
and I go look at you [ __ ] nervous man
and then I just started like going in
I'm like how do you really like I'm 24.
I'm like stop talking like that
and then I asked the girl like
um yeah 24. yeah that's the lady how old
are you and she's like I'm 28 and then
and I went oh to the dude and I went
and it was just funny I was trying to
kind of set him up but yeah SOLO queuing
at a comedy show you got to respect it
man ballsy yeah truly ballsy going to
any event by yourself is a ballsy move
the mother ever done that never gone to
an event yeah neither I don't think
gotta respect it yeah people are just
like no I'm just here for the music it's
tough yeah some introversions of like
like that yeah that's true I love that
yeah always goes to solo movies you go
to movies by yourself if I want to see a
movie it's annoying like will it just be
filming something he's like I gotta go
I'm gonna watch a movie
foreign
don't leave to go hang out by yourself
like that's annoying that's [ __ ]
weird at least invite me dog not even
I'm like just don't do that so you're
going by yourself cool do you wanna I
mean I'm not doing anything so yeah
literally he's like all right yeah cool
that's fine or just like a concert or
something for someone you like but like
you would go to a concert by yourself
yeah you don't want to do it the other
day you don't understand there's like
this small dude that I like dude his
name's Jeffrey Martin okay he just was
doing a show in Santa Barbara so I just
drove to Santa Barbara went to the show
you drove all the way to Santa Barbara
and went to a concert yeah yeah and you
weren't lonely or no I love being by
myself I was gonna say thank you but
like when I'm home I was gonna say when
I met his dad his dad put it in the most
loving way possible he goes ah cash man
I I have so much respect for that guy he
when he wants something he goes for it
and as as long as I've known cash it
[ __ ] freaks me out how just solo he
will be this would do would go to
Coachella by himself like he does things
that make me say like don't
just stop it makes makes you makes me
socially nervous yeah yeah he was
thinking about him yeah scenario yeah
I'm like don't do that just don't meet
people there if you want and say what
hey I don't know
you already have a problem
hey you already have a common interest
like you're at the thing yeah but I feel
like that then you become that guy
that's like you know that someone's
having a conversation you're like yeah
yeah no no no I usually don't do
anything I just mean if you don't want
to be alone like you wouldn't have to be
but like I don't normally I don't seek
out anyone else I love this confidence
well if you don't want to be alone you
don't have to be yeah I prefer to be
alone but if you're like weird and you
need to lean on you you just said you
meet people there no if I had to like if
for some reason I was feeling lonely
which I wouldn't but like if I was
feeling lonely I don't know people feel
that sometimes people get lonely or
whatever it is